foreign
Queens New York what's up Anna
you
Anna are you there I'm here can you hear
me yeah what's up I'm sorry I'm Hi how
are you oh don't be sorry you're up to
you you're good it's an honor to talk to
you how are you I am so nervous right
now I'm like shaking are you kid Anna
seriously Have you listened to the show
oh my God like you wouldn't believe I
watched your YouTube videos all the time
so it's really weird to just hear your
voice okay but listen you know I'm not
very good at this you have nothing to be
nervous about at all I assure you
um so what's up how can I help
okay so um in preparation for this call
because I know
I know I'm super nervous I wrote
everything down so I'm just going to
read off like a little script here yes
you are a saint good for you I I need to
take lessons from you on how to just be
a better human so okay go for it okay so
my question is uh when facing arguments
or disagreements in a relationship how
can I change my mindset from a me versus
you mentality to an US versus the
problem
so um I wrote out some like background
so my boyfriend and I have been together
for almost two years and we moved in
together back in June of last year from
the beginning we were very open and
honest about what we wanted out of our
relationship we shared our values and
thoughts on what we wanted our futures
to look like and found that we wanted
the same thing he's kind thoughtful a
super dork and all around hilarious and
I just love him to pieces he's actually
the reason how I became a listener of
your show he found Dave Ramsey in an
attempt to help me figure out how to pay
off my debt and if my calculations are
accurate I should be debt free by the
end of this year way to go very cool
thank you he has been such a rock and
support system throughout this
tumultuous Journey making sure to wipe
my tears away when I've reached my limit
to offer me advice and words of
encouragement when I need a most and
truly walking beside me every step of
the way
uh when it comes to my part in our
relationship I truly struggle with
voicing my needs especially when it
comes to arguments what I try to say
comes out entirely wrong and actually
makes the argument much worse because it
starts with me wanting to present why
I'm feeling upset but the way I
communicate it ends up hurting him and
escalating the situation
stop right there I'm gonna dig in real
quick where does it
where does that come from
when when was it communicated to you
that your needs didn't matter
I'll like essentially my entire life
okay yeah and
so I want you imagine you um you're in
Queens right so imagine
um you left queens and just were dropped
into Mexico City
everyone's speaking Spanish
it would be really frustrating because
you you you're trying to communicate
you're trying to be a good human you're
trying just to get some food you're
trying to get some like take care of
your like leaky pipe in your apartment
but you don't speak Spanish and so
you're learning Spanish and you're
practicing and you're trying you're
going to stumble through it and you're
going to look up in two or three years
later you're gonna be
almost fluent right because you've been
practicing
think of expressing your needs like that
okay so just like more practice it's
being very gentle with yourself
and saying one of your needs out loud to
your boyfriend which is I'm gonna say
this probably the wrong way is now a
good time
and so he can go okay and if you if you
tell him hey I'm trying to learn how to
express my needs Express what I need
and he may need to practice on hearing
somebody else's needs because he may
have grown up in a home where his job
was to make sure everybody was okay
and if somebody has a need then his body
responds as you're failing and mom's
gonna get pissed and rip the cabinets
off the wall
and you see how couples do this dance
together where I don't really know how
to save my needs and I bottle them up
bottom up and then you just explode as a
good New Yorker and then he is a
peacekeeper I just got to make sure Dad
doesn't get pissed and Mom doesn't drink
too much and I gotta got it and then all
sudden he gets this explosion and he
shuts down and now we're in this
loop-de-loopy loop-de-loop is that fair
yeah no sir
um uh should I should I continue yeah of
course continue yeah yeah
um so uh the original issue gets pushed
aside and then the argument is no longer
about the issue I presented but more of
how I'm hurtful and careless with my
work
so this has been an ongoing pattern in
our arguments and in our most recent
argument he said that he feels I
approach issues with the mentality that
it's me against him and he often feels
like I'm attacking him when he's trying
his best in our relationship and when I
thought about it I realized he was
bright as you say are you do you attack
him
so my perspective is like so I never
yell I never curse you know I don't I
don't come off aggressive but
um when I'm upset you can like taste it
in the air you know like I'm assuming
right and I just get very quiet and so
he'll like he'll very gently come over
and be like hey are you okay or do you
want to talk about it and then I'll just
very like calmly say you know I'm
feeling this because of you know you're
doing this or you're not doing this and
I would appreciate if you did that but
then he's like you don't necessarily
just because you're speaking calmly to
me doesn't mean that your words are oh
dude that's an old yeah that is an old
uh
um
that's an old male trick
that where you become this radioactive
Center my wife calls it Sunday afternoon
dad like this like just sitting on the
couch in this pulsing energy and anybody
who's like hey what's wrong and you're
like nothing why are you always
bothering me and Hassle and all of a
sudden it's like whoa right you said
something really really important
you said when he asks you hey what's
wrong you said you're making me feel dot
dot dot
and I call bullcrap on that
you are choosing
to feel XYZ
and that's the real question why are you
why is your body shutting you down why
is it feelings are like are like um sign
the road signs why is your body telling
you exit here
why is your body telling you slow down
and go one mile an hour because there's
a wreck ahead
why is it telling you that that's it's
the gosh whenever someone says this word
I roll my eyes but it's so true that's
mindfulness
why is my but it's being curious why is
my body so mad right now because that
guy loves me
we're on the same team I really wish
he'd pick a socks up so stupid that he
won't pick a socks up but I know he
loves me
why is my body responding as though
we're breaking up and this is it and he
slept with my best friend like you see
what I'm saying like it just gears up
that's where
you take ownership of how your body's
responding to a situation and then from
that
you you might have some very very very
real needs
you are absolutely disrespecting me you
are abusing me you are in the same way
you can by the way you can control the
house not by yelling not by swearing but
just being this this gravitational pull
of all joy and happiness
he can
hide his frustration and and
disappointment and anger and shame with
a big old smiley face and I'm bringing
you your cup of coffee just like you
like it he can hide there too
oh my God that's actually pretty pretty
fine because he he does say that
um when we had this our most recent
argument he did mention that like the
things that you're upset about he's like
they aggravate me too because you do
them as well but I choose to look at the
bigger picture right like I love this
woman you know I see a future together
we're going to get married like this is
the one for me and she's going through a
lot right now like I work two jobs you
know because of being on this debt-free
journey and everything so I'm constantly
busy and tired and he's like I can
Overlook like if she leaves her teacup
on the table but if I do it it's a whole
thing so he really wishes that I could
just take a step back and just look at
everything that we have and every like
you know all the love that we have in
this house and you know how much we love
each other and support one another and
just think like you know that's enough
like he's and not to not to like he's
not saying that my needs are not
important you know but he's like and
he's more than happy to help meet my
needs but he would really appreciate it
if at first I just kind of looked took a
step back and looked at everything and
see how I feel after
would you like that that sounds like a
much more peaceful way of living
100 but it's just I don't
something
like I see red yeah and I'm not violent
I'm not violent but I'll kill him to
death so here's what I want you to do
okay two things
um is there a is there a cultural divide
here y'all y'all have different
um racial ethnic backgrounds
okay
um this is super common too where
there's a I don't say a cultural
mismatch because it makes it sound like
it's it's dysfunctional but there is
just here's the way we talk in our house
right um I was talking to the the Great
Master therapist Terry reel Terence real
and
um I was asking about yelling because I
I've just come to believe that yelling
is abusive and he in his I think his
example was
it is unless you're a family in New
Jersey and that's the way you talk to
each like it's just that ah shut up and
it's it's a it's part of the culture
right or I grew up in Texas and my
friends who were first gen Mexican
Americans who very different approach to
like hey there's an issue here I got
real stoic and quiet and they may get
fill in the blank right so I think
there's a call out the cultural mismatch
there or hey I'm not you're gonna love
me what what are what is the different
um ethnic backgrounds
um he's Asia okay
and I'm a white Jewish
oh fantastic this is gonna be
spectacular spectacular right so I could
make all the generalizations here right
that I learned in grad school I won't do
that but
ask yourself has he been trained to
respond in in way X and you've been
trained to respond in way why okay and
there may be a mix match there so you
may be you may be swimming more Upstream
than you think it may not be that you're
broken it may be that the way you were
trained to engage in an issue
is was really helpful in this context
we're gonna have to create new contacts
together in this new relationship okay
so that's number one number two on a
very practical skill here's what I want
you to do this is going to cost you
probably 79 cents are you ready for this
investment
okay you may have to work a third job to
pull this one off but we can do it okay
I want you to go down to a quarter
market like CVS or Walgreens or
something like that I want you to get a
deck of
um
I want you to get a package of uh note
cards okay
I've got a hard writing deadline and
I've been up
uh into the mornings for the last two
weeks and my words aren't coming so I
want you to get a pack of note cards
and when you get mad
when you see a quote-unquote problem
I want you to pull out one of those note
cards and write the problem down
and before you engage him
before you start picking at him or
yelling or starting to see as you're
starting to see red I want you to put
that card down on a table and I want you
to have the conversation about that
problem with him sitting next to you on
your side of the table
so you are both facing the quote-unquote
problem the issue
okay and here's what that's going to do
you're going to see a cup that he left
out overnight he's gonna have like that
little bit of coffee left in the rim
it's staying in the cup and it's just
gross and it's gonna be sitting on the
coffee table and you're gonna see it
and you're gonna get insta-pissed
because that coffee cup means he doesn't
love you and he never listens to you and
he's disgusting and he's going to raise
kids who are slobs right you're Off to
the Races
I want you to grab a note card in that
moment and write it down and write down
on that note card he left out coffee cup
comma he doesn't love me or respect me
and I want you to set that on a table
and I want you to call him in
and then say hey
we need to talk about a problem you see
like how absurd this is and he's gonna
sit by you and you're gonna be like you
left a coffee mug out
and my body feels like you hate me
and y'all can both just stare together
shoulder by shoulder side by side at
this problem
and now I'm making fun of the problem
some of the problems may be big right
you don't come home when you say you're
going to
um you are you you pretend to be a
champion but you really are pretty
subversive about this thing I don't feel
safe around you you pressure me to do
things I don't want to do right so some
of these things may be real
but if we're in this relationship
together
remember this line
if you win and he loses you both lose
okay so going to war against him is not
going to help the relationship solving
these challenges that will pop up and by
the way these will pop up for the rest
of your relationship with him forever
and ever and ever amen until the end of
time
the goal is not to come up with a
challenge free or disagreement-free
relationship that's that's a boring way
to live that means neither of you are
trying very hard we've got to come up
with a way that we can always come back
to the table on the same side and solve
these things together does that make
sense
and have the courage and the strength to
say I'm my wife has done this to me okay
I'll just give you some insight into my
house
she will get she'll see red on something
and I'll take it so personal and she
will look at me and not smile but kinda
smile and she will say John not
everything is about you
not all of my Smiles all of my happiness
is because of you and not all of my
anger is because of you not everything's
about you and he's gonna have to learn
that sometimes when you see red has
nothing to do with him
right and he's gonna have to learn to
not take things so personal in the same
way that you might have to learn to back
up 30 000 feet detach a little bit and
realize hey we gotta there's a there's a
much longer game we're playing here he's
really tired he's exhausted he didn't
leave the cup out because he hates me he
left the cup out because man what is
going on in his life that's a shift from
judgment to curiosity
from anger and rage to hospitality
see there's a wet towel in the middle of
the floor
it's because he's disgusting and gross
and I hate him or there's a wet towel on
the floor what in the world this
happened in his world where he just left
it there something must be going on one
of those is a shift to curiosity one of
those but again
put wet towel on that on that piece of
paper on that note card put it in the
desk and be like how do we solve this
one
and man you're gonna find that your most
of your problems most of the time
dissipate like a vapor and the real
challenge is the real relational issues
that pop up
you're gonna be able to look at them
side by side and say hey let's go tackle
these things together